all right this is a fox news alert
breaking news out of texas where two
inmates believed to be ms-13 gang
members were killed at a federal
penitentiary in beaumont prompting a
nationwide lockdown for the entire
federal prison system we're going to
continue to monitor this story now
biden's border neglect is getting worse
by the second as the president today
claimed that all we need to do to solve
the border crisis is figure out now why
do illegal immigrants come here in the
first place are you really that dumb joe
and it gets worse because we have more
evidence of growing tensions inside the
border patrol amid the biden
administration's all-out disregard for
the rule of law aiding and abetting law
breaking listen to this exchange between
the border chief
and rank and file standing up to him
last week in laredo texas as the failed
dhs secretary mayorkas
visited the area watch this
i get it you come to work you're
frustrated you're upset because you
didn't get the desired outcome that you
want
it doesn't mean you give up
right
i know you're not that's why i'm saying
we don't give up i've been doing this
job as long as y'all that's the problem
what's that that's the problem
for people the truth is for good men to
do nothing i can't hear you for evil the
triumph is for good men to do nothing
that's exactly what's happening here
good men are doing nothing you're
allowing the legal agency to drop all
the communities
wow here with reaction leo 2.0 terrell
along with america first legal founder
stephen miller uh who's doing some great
work with his legal firm leo start with
you um
when you think that that never happens
where an agent will stand up to achieve
a boss like that and be that bold in
that blunt but it really was warranted
it was necessary because sean there's a
disconnect between the byte
administration that wants open border
and the border rank-and-file officers
who was who signed up to control the
border and prevent illegal aliens from
coming in they have the byte
administration have turned the border
officers into travel agents they have
basically now accommodate criminals
illegal agents to designate them to any
place in this country they have flipped
it around the border patrol agents are
frustrated they don't want to be travel
agents they want to keep illegal aliens
out of this country and they're being
denied by the by the administration and
the progressive left
steve miller
if you or i decided this is actually a
joke not even a great lawyer like leo
2.0 terrell could save us if we pick and
choose the laws
that we obey and those we choose not to
obey we'd go to jail
if you and i were helping illegal
immigrants cross into this country i
think we'd probably be charged with
something like human trafficking is that
not true
yeah there would be severe and lengthy
prison sentences in fact if you as a u.s
citizen present your arrest warrant to a
law enforcement officer you'll be placed
in handcuffs not boarded as illegal
aliens are onto planes and taken to the
destination of their choice
i know because i speak to border agents
i know because i still have good
contacts inside dhs they are enraged
they signed up they put on that green
uniform because they wanted to protect
this country and enforce our laws and
this administration is ordering them to
violate the laws they swore to uphold
for joe biden to say we want to find out
why they're coming here
people from 160 nations are coming here
for the very simple reason that donald
trump's policies of detain and remove
were replaced with joe biden's policies
of catch and release into the united
states of america why are they coming
here leo it's simple because they're
coming from countries that don't provide
hope opportunity and this this dream
that we all take for granted how hard is
that to figure out
it's not hard see the democratic party
see these as potential democratic voters
that's the reason why they're being
allowed there let's be clear these these
are the future democratic voters chaos
criminals people who are coming over
here illegally breaking the law
something of great value it's called
citizenship last word stephen miller
joe biden is diluting and damaging
citizenship by allowing people to come
into this country in violation of our
laws their first act on this soil is to
disrespect our sovereignty rather than
people who come here take the oath do it
right and join our family and community
all citizens of all backgrounds from all
places should be deeply outraged
yeah you know what i'll support
immigration legal immigration like my
grandparents came here legally and you
know what i don't care where you come
from if you go through the process you
come in legally we do a background check
we do a health check make sure you can
provide for yourself welcome to our
family do it the right way uh stephen
miller thank you leo 2.0 thank you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else